So we've talked about problems with content-based filtering.
What about IP blacklists? Well, first, the way an
IP blacklists works is that when a sender
sends an email to the receiver the receiver sends
a query for that IP address to a
blacklist or a DNS-based blacklist sometimes called a DNSBL
such as spamhaus. Depending on whether or not that
IP address appears in the blacklist the receiver can
then decide to accept the message or, if the
IP address turns out to be on the blacklist,
the receiver can decide to terminate the connection and
not even accept the mail in the first place,
thereby saving the operator the trouble of even having
to store the message. The third approach is to
filter a message on how it is sent. In
particular, we can look at such features as the geographic
locations of the sender and receiver, the set
of target recipients, the sender's upstream ISP or
our inference as to whether the sender is a member of a botnet or a network of
comprised hosts that are doing the bidding of
some command and control server. Now the challenges
of buildling a filter around this notion is
first, understanding network level behavior and second, building classifiers
using network level features to execute the filtering.